juste vous dire ces gens ont énormément
de talent dans ma vie la sas et les
zinédine zidane du stand up c'est sûr et
certain et et qui a à nouveau une espèce
de nouvelle mouvance au même titre que
le summer foule hip hop quand il est
arrivé en france j'ai l'impression que
de plus en plus il ya des petits la sq
avait des petites têtes et qui de plus
en plus trop dans l'intérêt à cet art
parce que c'est vraiment un truc
spécifique le stand-up et il ya de plus
en plus de jeunes qui s'y intéressent a
dû il ya un vrai mouvement quoi tu vois
j'ai quand je disais que c'était l'été
une étude c'est sûr sociologique que
c'est pas loin je pense vraiment ça me
rappelle le hip hop quand ça arrive en
référence au débat
il ya un engouement autour de ce truc et
je trouve ça formidable plus on est de
fous plus on rit j'ai encouragé le
maximum de jeunes nous ont envoyé des
des cassettes
n'hésitez pas à vous faire connaître il
est dangereux ça s'est passé un peu de
la même manière avec tout le monde c'est
certain ça s'est fait par hasard pour la
plupart d'entre eux et le hasard fait
bien les choses
le ciel sauter de 10 heures thomas
n'gijol comat commence au théâtre de dix
heures à partir du mois de septembre
fabrice éboué vous voyez là ouais au
théâtre de dix heures à partir du mois
de septembre et pas de ça dit l'amour
c'est fait
merci d'avoir été avec les os x
e